[Music]
maybe is who you're working for and what
you're pursuing this video got widely
spread in Taiwan if my mom is watching
why don't you it's awesome world
business experience WBE garyvee coming
to town WB [ __ ] September 19th I'm
coming after you okay
September 27th Warsaw outside of your
normal kind of prom oh I they want just
a quick run out who you are just
described understood world business
experience September 27 Poland Warsaw
yeah but you gotta use that clip in the
line of luck I think people gonna love
it I think people are gonna finally have
that aha moment like oh that's his
content style
it's WWF 1987 promo videos but you think
[ __ ] JD why he is here for oh did I
send you the liquor out of here no no no
no no no yes yes yes I mean this is the
entire thing the vlog should be about
this is the entire blog right here yes
yes yes yes yes
a dirty Hillbilly Jim I got a clean one
all right
a horrible car Schnur don't sleep on the
Corporal there we go Kershner could [ __ ]
drag the [ __ ] hammer Valentine don't
sleep the hammer come down on your super
heart if you're sleeping don't sleep on
the hammer
do not sleep on the hammer Brutus the
barber beefcake these two were tag-team
champions if you don't know [ __ ]
beefcake baby
beefcake this the barber beefcake
terrible Terry Funk but you know about
terrible Terry Funk
nothing hurt uh-huh it's cuz you are
wack you are wack so you don't know who
terrible Terry Funk is let's go let's go
the Hulkster what you gonna do one the
24-inch pythons yeah all right cowboy
Bob or in Cowboy Bob Orton this og
WrestleMania
I know people know about Cowboy Bob
enough huh that's the special delivery
Jones guys don't know about St John's
lost a quickest match of all time to
King Kong Bundy if you don't know now
you know Paul mr. wonderful Orndorff
beast his piledriver is still like
grossly underestimated his skill set mr.
wonderful another WrestleMania 100g King
Kong [ __ ] Bundy boys I'm gonna put
him with st Jones is the guy who beat
him in like set [ __ ] 10 seconds King
Kong Bundy another jyd let's double it
up that's right
okay you know what that is
Jimmy Superfly Snuka come on guys
Superfly what I just know the memory
like thank you sure how's a big dude you
know this is right
Big John Studd boys Big John Studd you
know this is [ __ ] governor of
Minnesota Jesse the body Ventura let's
go come on you definitely know this is
this captain Lou albano you [ __ ]
idiots that's Nick Foley Mick Foley
get out of here oh these are here yes oh
my god yes
Sam dartle t-shirts baby but this is
[ __ ] the best day ever
Oh Quincy a nun wha these are [ __ ]
fresh
these are [ __ ] awesome okay what yeah
yeah I'm in rotation
Poland September 27th World Business
Expo Poland September 27th world
business experience I'm giving the
keynote my first time in Warsaw you know
I I know there's probably some of you
that don't know who I am and I'm I'm an
entrepreneur born in Belarus
we're neighbors came to the US grew up
very entrepreneurial lemonade stands
baseball cards always making a buck
making a couple thousand dollars a
weekend when I was a kid
eventually joined my dad's liquor store
business took it from a three to a 60
million dollar ecommerce business became
an early investor in facebook twitter
and tumblr uber snapchat Pinterest went
on to build a very large global agency
called vaynermedia five time New York
Times bestselling author and arguably
the greatest keynote speaker of all time
according to my mom and dad I'm going to
bring the Thunder I'm gonna give you the
State of the Union the opportunity the
global nature of my agency allows me to
understand what's happening in a Polish
and an Eastern European market from an
influencer standpoint from a Facebook
standpoint from a Twitter standpoint
from a digital Samantha Moyer at Google
standpoint a blog standpoint a vlog
standpoint of you standpoint a podcast
standpoint I'm bringing standpoints
Poland are you gonna join me honestly
honestly I think literally from the
first second that's exactly what you
need to see like the whole thing like
yeah show that
[Music]